associer la culture au business à
travers le sport c'était l'objectif que
s'étaient fixés les entreprises à
repartage esther europe lors de
l'événement swing hard cup au total une
soixantaine d'architectes bailleurs
sociaux élus locaux ou encore promoteurs
se sont rencontrés au golf de bêtement
au programme initiation au golf pour les
débutants parcours pour les plus initiés
et déambulation à travers les stands de
plusieurs artistes on se dit mais en
fait il n'ya jamais eu d'événements qui
mélangeait l'art et l'architecturé et le
bâti et le monde du bâtiment c'est vrai
que moi je dis je répète souvent que
dans architecture les trois premières
lettres ca et les architectes sont avant
tout des artistes mais dans les
événements du bâtiment on ne voit jamais
d'artistes s'exprimer en tant qu'artiste
donc l'idée c'était de mélanger ce monde
ce monde la volonté c'est vraiment de de
dire ben voilà c'est un événement qui
est différent qui est inédit mais
surtout avec la culture on a on donne
quelques petites clés de ce que l'on
pourrait faire pour vos entreprises dans
le monde du bâtiment dans la
construction avec les salariés objectif
permettre aux invités de se faire des
contacts dans un cadre ludique convivial
est différent des salons traditionnels
portraitiste artistes peintres ou encore
photographes ont répondu présent un
trophée a également été dessinée par un
créateur sculpteur plasticien et remis
aux trois gagnants ils choisissaient
leurs casquettes customisés ensuite ils
allaient voir l'artiste peintre donc ça
permettait des échanges autour d'une
grande toile on avait regroupé
l'ensemble de toutes les casquettes
qu'elle avait réalisé j'ai décidé de
faire un dessin unique pour chaque
casque est donc 66 casquette au niveau
technique rien qu'au niveau du dessin
c'était la première fois que je
dessinais des grues des maisons de cette
façon là voilà j'ai découvert un peu le
milieu du bâtiment aussi à travers mon
travail et c'est super une journée qui
faisait office de test mais que les
organisateurs comptent bien renouveler
l'année prochaine